resisting globalism and winning that's
the focus of tonight's angle that's
often lost in the Kohen call me Flynn
Muller shuffle a more important issue
far more important with a far greater
impact and reach the threat of globalism
we're not for the leadership vision and
the hard work of the Trump
administration we can be looking at a
much less free and prosperous USA over
the next hundred years
the president's instincts pushing for a
border wall renegotiating NAFTA
insisting on fair trade with China our
spot on America will always choose
independence and cooperation over global
governance control and domination I
honor the right of every nation in this
room to pursue its own customs beliefs
and traditions the United States will
not tell you how to live for work or
worship we only ask that you honor our
sovereignty in return almost every
important issue
Trump has held firm even in the face of
immense resistance from those who have
made billions on the failed promise of
globalism America is governed by
Americans we reject the ideology of
globalism and we embrace the doctrine of
patriotism but the president has faced
enormous opposition in his efforts and
not just from outside his own party this
was his former director of the National
Economic Council Garrett Cohen this
morning I'm absolutely not offended by
the term globalist guys I am achill it
was I believe we live in a globalized
world
I think the United States is a very
integral part of a globalized world and
we have to figure out how to live as a
good citizen the globalizers
so do the Chinese so do the Russians so
did the Middle Eastern countries but we
are globalized we cannot change that
fact well we have to figure out how to
be good global citizens well that might
sound really high-minded what's happened
in the
20 years since China entered the WTO is
not pretty we ended up in reaching other
countries and lots of Wall Streeters
like Cohen himself as our own middle
class suffered thousands of US companies
moved overseas for cheaper production
all assured in under the banner of
globalization going gone were most
american-made products from textiles to
toys to televisions sure wasn't what the
globalist told us what happened once
China was welcomed into the world trade
community by joining the WTO China is
not simply agreeing to import more of
our products it is agreeing to import
one of Democracies most cherished values
economic and freedom the more China
liberalizes its economy the more fully
it will liberate the potential of its
people their initiative their
imagination their remarkable spirit of
enterprise well how did that work out
Chinese are rich or sure but we have a
three hundred and seventy five billion
dollar annual trade deficit with China
and the only imagination they brought to
the game is in their plotting to steal
America's innovations eighteen years
after China's entrance into the WTO even
Trump's most ardent critics are
conceding that basically he's right
let's be honest on one big fundamental
point Donald Trump is right China is a
trade sheet the US Trade
Representative's report to Congress on
China's compliance with global trading
rules is an exception worth reading
little lays out the many ways that China
has failed to enact promised economic
reforms backtracked on others and used
formal and informal means to block
foreign firms from competing in China's
market all of which directly contradicts
Beijing's commitments when it joined the
World Trade Organization in 2001 bingo
but even as the Intelligencia begin to
recognize reality some liberal
do-gooders in Hollywood in Silicon
Valley are m.i.a they're willing to bow
to the Chinese censors to maintain
access to the marketplace desperate to
capture the Chinese box office industry
execs forego most any project that would
offend their Chinese overlords where's
that mouth film mr. Spielberg scripts
are altered movie posters readers
and previews edited all to please their
communist business partners now
ironically the Hollywood crowd claims to
be vigilant guardians of artistic
expression and they give tedious
speeches that award shows about living
your truth all the while they avoid the
inconvenient truth about how day in and
day out China brutalizes dissidents both
religious and political the AP is
reporting that a million Muslims are
housed in internment camps in China and
one facility they're forced to make
clothing that despite being a violation
of US law has made its way to an
American sportswear supplier and this
Christmas season I ask you to remember
what's happening to China's estimated
100 million Christians house church
pastors and underground bishops are
arrested for being threats to the state
churches are bulldozed crosses ripped
off steeples parishioners are forced to
celebrate in secret and there are
reports that the regime is subjected
Fallone gong members to forced organ
harvesting the Khashoggi murder murder
by the Saudis is still making news and
Trump is faulted for his response but
there's no equivalent media coverage a
condemnation of China for its widespread
ongoing horrific human rights violations
access to the Chinese market has turned
captains of industry into silent Stooges
and frankly enablers Qualcomm and the
Chinese companies have been working
together for many years to drive new
technologies a lot of growth in Qualcomm
business has come from working with
Chinese companies the Chinese government
and Chinese partners understand that VR
valuable partner in upgrading their
industries we see that China is becoming
much more positive toward intellectual
property protection yeah we believe it I
mean while the political class is afraid
of Goldman Sachs hedge funds and any big
business that stupidly stakes so much of
its future on a communist country so the
globalist don't really resist China they
resist Trump and are fighting the
president urging him to back off his
tough trade policies with China if you
look at the arithmetic of Chinese
exports the United States aus to China
and what the impact of tariffs is again
it drives things in the wrong direction
I think in the long term that's actually
bad for American manufacturing not a
good thing the way that it's being done
right now is not having a positive
impact on the businesses and could
potentially impact the workers now these
are many of the same people who fought
him on NAFTA and are objecting to a
border wall that's funny how it works
it's like a Venn diagram for the moment
the president is standing firm since
they joined the WTO we've racked up four
point five trillion dollars in trade
deficits with China
year after year politicians ran for
office promising to fix our horrible
trade deals and I took it on and that's
right when they charged us two tariffs
we charged them a tariff now okay I
don't blame these other countries I
blame our past leadership for allowing
these other countries to get away with
it now they have a kind of 90-day
cooling-off period but he should not
relent why shouldn't he relent because
tariffs are working this from the hill
today tariffs have contributed to this
growth both directly and indirectly in
the four main areas where tariffs are
imposed steel aluminum solar panels and
washing machines the US has directly
added more than 11,000 jobs as of August
since then more investments and jobs
have been announced including a massive
1.5 billion dollars steel plant by steel
dynamics that will employ some 600 work
and in the solar arena solar power World
magazine lists more than a dozen US
companies where new facilities have been
started and or expanded good stuff only
the United States my friends has the
economic and moral might to keep China's
global ambitions in check and as she
continues his ruthless consolidation of
power along with aggressive global
expansion both parties need to consider
this question will you support policies
that strengthen the hand of a murderous
communist regime in China or the
policies that ensure a prosperous strong
independent America it's a time for
choosing and that's the angle